good evening everyone thank you very
much for coming
um first a few words on the process
you were all pulled on your way in on
your
opinion for our uh our motion tonight
hitler's pope
pius xii did too little to save the jews
from the holocaust
you were polled on the way in and i will
give you the result of that poll
after we've heard the opening speeches
and you will be pulled at the end now
you should have a ticket
and that ticket should have a little for
against
make sure you hang on to it for the the
vote
at the end and if you're still undecided
at the end of the evening's debate
then take both pieces and put them into
the urn
that comes around good so that's for the
the voting process our motion tonight
hitler's pope
pius xii did too little to save the jews
from the holocaust
is a is an important topic and indeed
for those who
watch this uh space something
significant happened in july of this
year which was that the holocaust
history museum
yad vashem changed its description
of pius xii and stated
that his reputation was not just
as the old label had it a matter of
controversy
but a matter of controversy amongst
scholars
you can infer from that what they
thought it previously was amongst
seems like no better time therefore for
intelligence squared
to uh make this debate a debate here
uh and a serious debate amongst scholars
um therefore let me immediately welcome
our first
speaker for the motion john julius
norwich
historian prolific author and author
amongst many other things of the pope's
history john julius norwich welcome
well ladies and gentlemen
on the 18th of may 1917
cardinal eugenio parcelli traveled by
train
from rome to munich as papal nuncio
bringing with him incidentally
60 cases of food in case german wartime
rations
should defend his delicate digestion
two years later in april 1919 during the
confusion following
the end of the first world war a trio of
bolsheviks
led by a certain max levine seized power
in bavaria
where they made life extremely difficult
for the diplomatic corps
pacelli who characteristically refused
to meet them himself
sent his deputy to register a protest
and reported back to the vatican
the scene of the palace was
indescribable the confusion chaotic
the filth nauseating a gang of young
women of dubious appearance
jews like all the rest of them hanging
around in all the offices with lecherous
demeanor and suggestive smiles
the boss of this female rebel was
levine's mistress
a young russian woman a jew and a
divorcee who was in charge
this levine is a young man about 30 or
35
also russian and a jew pale dirty with
drugged eyes
hoarse voice vulgar repulsive with a
face
that is both intelligent and sly
i don't think julius striker could have
done much better than that
much was to be written in later years of
pastor twelfth's love for the jewish
people
but i think uh that quotation surely
suggests that such reports may have been
somewhat exaggerated
on matters of color on the other hand he
made no pretense a quarter of a century
later
as pope we find him asking the british
foreign office for assurances
that no colored troops would be among
the small number that might be
garrisoned in rome
on the occupation on the other hand
he had a passion for germany on march
6 1939 just four days after his election
as pope
a year after hitler's annexation of
austria and with german troops already
messing
on the czechoslovak frontier he
personally drafted a letter
to the illustrious hair adolf hitler
fuhrer
and chancellor of the german reich here
at the beginning of our pontificate
we desire to express the wish to remain
united by deeds of profound and
benevolent friendship
with the german people who are entrusted
to your care
now this letter was not only the first
addressed by the new pope to any head of
state
but we also have the word from one of
the official
uh historians of pope pius xii that
and i quote in length and in the
sentiments it expresses
it differs totally from the other
official letters sent by the vatican
at that time well on the first of
september 1939
the wehrmacht marched into catholic
poland
over the next five weeks the polls lost
some seventy thousand men
from the vatican however there came not
a word
of revulsion or regret still less of
denunciation
this deafening silence continued until
the third week of october
when the pope published his first
encyclical
now at last poland received a mention
the blood of countless human beings
non-combatants among them
has been shed and cries out to heaven
especially the blood of poland
a nation very dear to us
well it was doubtless better than
nothing but look at that phrase
non-competence among them which somehow
suggested there were relatively few of
these
rather than the vast majority and
nowhere in the text is there any mention
of germany or nazis or jews
hitler as we know had no similar
compunction
the jews he declared on the 9th of
february 1942
will be liquidated for at least a
thousand years
within a month active persecution
persecution was underway
not only in germany austria and poland
but in hungary croatia slovakia
and in marshall peters unoccupied france
before the end of the year the mass
deportations had begun
42 000 french jews had been packed off
to auschwitz alone
in september president roosevelt sent a
personal envoy to the pope
to beg him to condemn the german war
crimes but still
there came not a word from rome the
papal secretary of state
secretary of state cardinal luigi
malione
would repeat only that the holy see was
doing all it
could it wasn't
if only because as 1942 due to its close
the vatican had something else on its
mind the possible bombing of rome
the british minister to the holy see sir
darcy osborne
was being summoned almost daily and
entrusted
to uh entreated to in to extract a firm
undertaking
from the british government that there
would be no air raids on the holy city
in vain he pointed out that britain was
at war and rome was an enemy capital
and even if the city were spared it was
highly unlikely that the italians would
be given advanced notice of the fact
finally on christmas eve the pope made a
broadcast to the world
it called on men of goodwill to make a
solemn vow
to bring back society to the center of
gravity
which is the law of god and it continued
mankind
owes that vow to the hundreds and
thousands of persons
who without any fault on their part
sometimes only
because of their nationality or race
have been consigned to death
or to a slow decline
and that was it once again no mention of
the jews
or the nazis or even of germany the
racial element had been toned down
by the addition of those two weasel
words sometimes only
while the millions of victims had been
reduced to hundreds and thousands
and what precisely is a slow decline
could that be what the auschwitz
survivors suffered
well now until now until 43
the jewish community in rome about 8 000
strong
have been allowed to live relatively
undisturbed but in july 43 everything
changed
the allies invaded sicily and bombed
rome mussolini was arrested
rome came under german occupation and on
the 18th of october
came the order to round up the jews what
was needed now
was for the pope to make a vehement
protest against this new outrage
which was taking place on his very
doorstep had he done so
he could very probably have prevented
the whole thing
but silence once again ensued and the
deportations went ahead
now papal apologists will tell us of the
numbers of jews who
in the later stages of the war in
particular owed their lives to the
intervention of the church
particularly in hungary though even here
things were pretty
slow in getting underway the germans
invaded hungary
on the 23rd of march 1944 and the
loathsome adolf eichmann began his work
at once
it was nearly two months later on the
15th of may
that the papal nuncio requested the
hungarian government
and i quote not to continue its war
against the jews
beyond the limits prescribed by the laws
of nature and god's commandments
surely a rather curious limitation and
the rescue operation
began in earnest only after a cable from
the pope himself
one again once again not mentioning the
jews by name on the 25th of june
after this thanks to the hungarian
church and the catholic laity alike
countless lives were saved and there
were other other heroes too
notably the perfectly splendid father
hugh flaherty
working inside the vatican saving not
only jews but escaped allied soldiers
the pope paid tribute to him at eastern
1945 a month before the end of the war
it would have been nice if he'd had the
courage to say so a little earlier with
rather more publicity and why did he not
because his terror of communism
a far greater bug bear to him than
germany nazi germany would ever be
or fear that any protest might result in
the german occupation of the vatican and
quite possibly his own imprisonment
either or both may be true but there are
other questions too
that demand explanation after the end of
the war he continued to spoke for
another 13 years
why was there not one word of apology or
regret not a single
requiem or massive remembrance for the
1989 jewish deportees from rome
who had met their deaths in auschwitz
alone why did the pope who cheerfully
excommunicated
all members of the communist party
across the world never apparently
consider
doing the same to the catholic nazi war
criminals
including himmler goebbels bormann and
of course hitler himself
and why until the very day of his death
did he refuse to recognize
the state of israel i'm looking forward
to hearing the answers to those
questions tonight
thank you very much john julius norwich
i'm very pleased to
welcome william dwino our first speaker
against the motion william duino is an
author who writes about religion history
and politics
he's contribute contributed an extensive
bibliography of works on
pius xii to the pious war responses to
the critics
of pius xii william do we know welcome
thank you very much
thank you very much to intelligence
squared to the distinguished panelists
and to everyone for being tonight i just
like to
correct my distinguished opponent john
julius norwich on a few things
he referred to cardinal eugenio pacelli
in 1917
he was not a cardinal until 1930.
yes that's the least of your errors i
should say
uh he referred to the the supposedly
anti-semitic letter
if he knew anything about the letter if
he read uh professor rislock's book he
he would know that that's complete
mistranslation he's giving the john
cornwall translation
it's been completely discredited he
never said for example jews like all the
rest of them
it's it was a mistranslation from german
into english so that's the second major
era
and then he referred a very serious
error he referred to
eugenio pachelli papayas the 12th uh not
wanting any black or colored troops
he never mentioned that he never
mentioned those with it was the british
ambassador
and just recently let me say i
discovered the testimony of one roy
otley who was the first
african-american correspondent who was
granted a special audience with pope
pius xii
and roy otley himself wrote dispatches
back to the united states and elsewhere
talking about how powerful a stan pope
pius
xii took against racism and he
associated that with the stand pope pius
xii was taking
on on behalf of the jews so right from
the very beginning
of this debate it's clear that mr
norwich did not do his homework
we asked the question who is eugenio
pacelli
who is the man that eventually became
pope pius xii
and what specifically did he do on
behalf of the persecuted u.s people
and in order to answer that question we
have to make a critical distinction
between the real historical papayas the
12th
and what might be called the
non-historical popeyes of 12.
i think we heard i think we had a good
example of the non-historical pies of
the 12th
in much of the commentary that we heard
from mr norwich
the reality is that the allegations that
he made against papaya's truth that he
was silent
that he was indifferent that he was the
state of israel
these are completely untrue the reality
is that at
every stage of his adult service to the
church when he was the papal nuncio in
germany
when he was the cardinal secretary of
state in the 1930s when he was the pope
himself during the 1930s and
1940s and 50s pope pius xii did take a
stand against
anti-semitism he did warn against adolf
hitler early on
and he did intervene on behalf of his
jewish brothers and sisters
let me cite you a few examples as early
as 1916
the department in which eugenio pacelli
the future of papayas 12th worked
issued a declaration condemning
anti-semitism that was recognized
throughout the world
in 1921 just two years after nazi party
formed he was warning his fellow
bavarians
not to allow the danger of communism to
blind them
to the danger the rising danger of
nazism just two years after
the hitler party was born in 1923
he writes to the vatican still 10 years
before
hitler obtains power warning them about
the fanatical anti-semitism as well as
anti-catholicism
of adolf hitler the following year
he writes another letter to the vatican
in which he predicts
that this fanatical nationalism that the
nazis are exhibiting
could well become the greatest dangerous
heresy of our time
in 1929 the year before he leaves
germany for good this is still four
years before hitler obtains power
he's warning everyone that he can talk
to that this man is a madman and he
cannot understand
as his personal assistant sister
pascalina mentions in her own memoirs
why the people of germany and elsewhere
do not see this
what what can be clearly seen this man
is a madman
he is capable of trampling on corpses
and destroying everything in his path
and then in 1930 the year he becomes
cardinal secretary of state
one of the first editorials that appears
in the news the vatican's official
newspaper
is one that declares the party of hitler
stands condemned by the ecclesiastical
authorities
and in the text of the body of that
editorial it says
national socialism nazism is
irreconcilable with the catholic
conscience
none of these facts was mentioned by mr
norwich
it's not surprising therefore that by
the time he is elected pope pius xii
the world welcomes pope pius the 12th
because he is the one of the few people
that has taken a stand
against this rising danger and he's one
of the few peop
evils of the time nazism and communism
after he becomes the pontiff he
immediately does five or six things that
establish him
as the powerful and effective leader he
is first of all he writes a blazing and
sickle mr
john julius my distinguished opponent
tried to minimize that in sickle but
this is what the new york times itself
wrote about that in sickle it said
presenting picture a picture of
contemporary life as devastating as any
of the old testament prophets could have
done
the pontiff proclaimed his determination
to step forward boley
racism the violation of trees recourse
to arms
the forcible transfer of populations the
destruction of poland
these and many principles dear to
fascism are condemned
it is germany that stands condemned
above any country or any movement
innocent sickle
the germany of hitler and national
socialism
that was that was the reaction to his
first and sickle that's hardly the words
of hitler's pope hardly the words of an
enabler
the other things that he does at that
time is that he immediate after the
nazis
invade poland in september of 1939 he
authorizes vatican radio to condemn the
nazis which
it does quite explicitly in the name of
the church
he then he then contacts the anti-nazi
german resistance very early on in the
war
and he gives his approval to a plot to
overthrow adolf hitler
in addition to this he instructs all his
papal nuncials
in all the nazi-occupied countries to
take a stand
in favor of the persecuted jewish
community and against the racial
persecutions
which they do several of those for
example angelo rata from hungary
andrea casullo from romania have already
been recognized and declared righteous
by yad the most distinguished holocaust
museum
in israel but it's not just that he
instructed others to take
up the cause of the persecuted jewry
during their darkest hour
he himself took personal actions
one of his finest hours which mr mr
norwich
unfortunately tried to downgrade was
during the german occupation of rome
the reality is that the germans
themselves tried to exterminate and they
targeted the entire jewish
community at that time thought to be
upwards of ten thousand jews
because of his quick and decisive action
because he sent not one but
not two but three protests and because
he instructed all the
the catholic religious and lady to open
their institutions and do whatever they
could
to save the persecute over 85 of rome's
jews were saved
it is not true that they were saved
because other people did so they did
they were saved because pope pius 12
issued his protest and he did take a
stand
and incidentally it is also not true
because i've spoken to many of the
catholic rescuers that he was signed
vatican radio was declaring what was
going on at the time
and they they were the catholic rescuers
themselves have said
pope pius xii was our leader we heard
his messages during those years
and because of that we rescue the jews
so he has things completely wrong
now it's it's often debated among
historians how many
how many jews did pope pius 12th and the
entire catholic church say
just recently a very distinguished
historian from germany
dr thomas breckenmarker said he thought
that it was
at least one hundred thousand that's on
the conservative side of the scale
i've actually interviewed sir martin
gilbert and when i asked him directly
how many he thought
that the entire catholic church under
the leadership of pope pius xii
saved he said it was in the hundreds of
thousands michael berlay
another great distinguished historian
also believes it's in the hundreds of
thousands so
what we are i want to stress here we are
not talking about a low scale or a small
uh intervention here and there we are
talking about a grand
global humanitarian effort that saved
more than any other individual or
institution at that time
under no circumstances therefore could
this resolution which says that he did
quote too little be taken seriously
in conclusion i'd just like to write
mention one
one story that many of you have probably
not heard about but i think which
symbolizes
the true worth and compassion of eugenia
pachelli pope pius xii
in 1917 the first time he got to as a
young people nancy
got to germany there was a jewish
musician by the name of ossep
gabrillowicz
ossep gabrilowicz was arrested on false
charges
because an anti-semitic pogrom was
accusing him of being a spy
his wife was desperate his whole family
was desperate they didn't know what to
do they didn't know who to turn to they
went to the politicians
they went to the police no one would
help them finally
they went to their own friend bruno
walter another jewish conductor
bruno walter was told in desperation the
only chance you have left
is to go to go to see a church official
perhaps he could head
and bruno walter to his great crate
went to see the now the very young very
new
eugenia pacelli the people nuncio and in
his memoirs theme and variations bruno
walters says
we spoke to the the very kind and
generous
people nuncio and he said the very next
day
the very next day ossep gabrilovich who
had faced execution
uh was a free man and it is of striking
significance ladies and gentlemen when
we talk about who eugenie pickeli the
real
pious 12th was that his very first
decisive act
as a papal nuncio as a career
church diplomat was to save the life of
a jewish musician from an anti-semitic
mob
that's the real popeye's 12th that's why
when he became pope 20 years later he
was such a good and compassionate leader
and i hope tonight we all open our eyes
and we see that thank you all very much
william william duino thank you very
much i'm very
pleased to welcome jeffrey robson qc
leading human rights lawyer
and the author of the case of the pope
vatican accountability for human rights
abuse
let me say as i say this that all of
these books will be out in the fire at
the end
and i'll sign them it's great to stand
in this
historic place of the dissection of
corpses
and uh we're not so much dissecting a
corpse tonight as the soul
of a man who could not bring himself to
speak out publicly
against the holocaust now when he
accepted the nobel peace prize elie
weissel who was a holocaust survivor
sent this message to all of that
persuasion who dare not speak out
against great evil
he said take sides neutrality
helps the oppressor never the victims
silence encourages the tormentor
never the tormented and this is a truth
that applies to the silence of pope pius
xii
in face of the most heinous crime
against humanity ever committed
even when it was taking place under his
very windows
he never spoke out he never let a candle
for christian morality that should have
shone in that blackness a blackness that
in consequence
covers him as well his silence gave
license to catholic members of the ss
to shoot the jewish men women and
children as they cowered on the edge of
the mass graves
it to turn on the gas in the
concentration camp chambers
and then to go to confession with an
untroubled conscience
it encouraged the germans in the belief
that god was still on their side
we shall see how the nazis desperately
needed the pope's silence
for that very reason they knew that any
complaint by the pontiff would damage
the war effort
and slow the progress of the final
solution
it gave so many catholics the excuse not
to help
jewish refugees although many did
it gave some catholics including quite a
few priests
the excuse to man the rat lines to help
the ss criminals
escape after the war to latin america
the pope's silence in face of this
overwhelming evil
was a deliberate choice it was an
immoral
and counterproductive choice how
different
this pope was to the catholic leaders
who helped to scupper
the nazi plan in the thirties to
liquidate the mentally ill
that was stopped when churchmen spoke
out
if you want a moving argument against
silence
read one joseph ratzinger who tells of
his
childhood our entire village he says in
nazi germany
experienced a sense of liberation
when cardinal clement of munich broke
the silence
and publicly defended the mentally ill
who'd been marked for extermination
how many other germans a few years later
might have experienced a spiritual
liberation
had the pope spoken up in similar terms
for the jews when they were marked for
extermination
i don't suggest that eugenio pachilli
was a nazi
he was an upper class italian aristocrat
who greatly feared the communists the
peculiar states
wouldn't have survived had they come to
power in italy
he shared the upper class suspicion of
the jews
ingrained in him was the long-standing
catholic condemnation of the race as the
sinners
who had killed christ but test it this
way
after the war when it was safe to do so
right up to his death
in 1958 pacelli never said prayers for
the holocaust victims not
one measly requiem mass and he totally
opposed the state of israel
refusing to recognize it as for the six
million jews of europe
he never lifted a bejeweled finger or
stretched a vocal cord
in their to save them why did he lack
the moral principle to say
loud and clear that the extermination of
the jewish race is wrong
when that hocketh play raised this
problem so dramatically in 1963
the first response of vatican apologists
was to claim that the pope didn't know
about it
when that didn't work they tried another
attack yes he knew all about it
but he didn't act because he didn't want
to make it worse
well how much worse could it be he
didn't act because he didn't want
catholics to suffer the same fate
really can you imagine hitler a himmler
a communicant catholic
gassing his own congregation he didn't
act they say because he had to stay
neutral in case he had to broker a truce
no one ever asked him to broker a truce
and a truth
truce with hitler that would leave the
nazis in place
was hardly on the cards after america
entered the war
so let us examine these excuses in turn
the notion he didn't know ridiculous he
knew all about the eustachian massacres
of jews in croatia in 1941
because anti-pavilic the movement's
founder was a fervent catholic
instead of excommunicating him he
welcomed him
to the vatican he was told of the final
solution
soon after it was planned at the wavonzi
villa
in february 1942 as one
book says quote in all likelihood the
vatican learned of the plan
shortly after the nazis decided decided
it
that's a quote from hitler the war and
the pope by ronald
richlack who'll speak next it began in
slovakia
in march the final solution when 80 000
jews
mainly women and children were deported
to certain death
still the pope did nothing had he done
anything
it would have had an effect because
slovakia was a catholic country
headed by president joseph tiso who
believe it or not was a priest the pope
heard about the gas chambers
from priests from church officials from
al
scavitzi who was a really a spy for the
vatican
working with the knights of malta he's
told the pope
that the massacre of the jews in ukraine
is by now nearly complete
and in october he said the two million
jews had already been killed by that
time the pope
knew of the special camps with the gas
chambers
informers from the waffen-ss and the
german military intelligence
passed a lot talk along the italian
ambassador to berlin
told him that even the ss talk openly
about the executions
bishop von prasing one of the pope's
closest friends
begged him to speak out to save the jews
of berlin who faced quote certain death
but uh of course he didn't and the
vatican records show that
by the end of 43 early 44
they were speaking of four million jews
lost in eastern europe
but even then the pope said nothing at
the end of the war when it was entirely
safe to do so
by speaking out then he might have
moderated those
final inhumanities in the camps and he
would certainly have discouraged
priests and catholic lay people from
helping the nazis to escape
justice and it's not credible to claim
that his neutrality was justified in
order to
broker retruce no one ever asked him
the apologists claim that papal
condemnation of the gas chambers would
have made hitler so angry that he would
have killed more jews
or perhaps even bombed the vatican but
this is nonsense
according to all we know of german
diplomacy and strategic
thinking the pope's neutrality was
central to the nazi strategy it was
essential to keep their soldiers
believing
that god was on their side or at least
on both sides
and it would shatter that belief if they
heard that the pope was not
now let's consider the case of the roman
jews
85 saved oh yes those
arrests when the germans came in and
rounded up a thousand jews
a big danger we have ribentrop the
foreign minister
and his envoy at the vatican von
weissicker
and we know what they said to each other
because we've got their telegrams
van wycker telegrams ribbon trop stop
himmler arresting
uh jews in rome or the pope might make a
public stand
which will serve anti-german propaganda
unquote really nervous that the pope
might speak out you see
this had become a propaganda war the
allies against the axis
democracy against fascism for the future
allegiance of the world it's not like
the first world war
where at christmas on the somber
contending armies would sing silent
night
and play each other at football and make
believe god was on both sides
this was a deadly ideological battle and
the question of the pope
was the question of whether god sided
against the extermination of the jews
and that is why the nazis so desperately
wanted the pope to say
stay silent and why von vizeker warned
ribentrop
that the roundup in rome might push him
over the edge
listen to his telegram to ribbontrop
about the roundup of the first thousand
jews
the curia is dumbfounded particularly as
the actions took place
under the very windows of the pope the
reaction could be muffled
if the jews were employed in labor camps
in italy
are you not sent to the gas chambers our
enemies are turning the action to their
own advantage
to force the vatican to drop its reserve
well the first deportation happened at
dawn
on october the 18th 1023 jews were
crammed into freight cars and
transported to auschwitz
820 of them were gassed within a week
only 17
returned throughout it all the pope
stayed silent
resisting all the pressure to condemn
this
wicked operation and von weisicker was
delighted he telegrammed rubentrop
the pope triumphantly the pope has not
allowed himself
to be stampeded into making any
demonstrative announcement
against the removal of the jews from
rome he's done
everything he could even in this
delicate
matter not to injure the relationship
between the vatican and the german
government
i the government and its extermination
policy that
telegram says it all the pope did
everything to help the nazis
and nothing to help the jews by
signaling through his silence
that god of whom he was the
representative on earth did not object
to genocide
he discredited and betrayed his own god
if he'd protested on the 18th of october
those freight cars
jammed with jews may not have left the
station the train might have been
diverted to morthausen which had no
gas chamber the italian resistance might
have been emboldened to attack
and release the prisoners had the pope
condemn the evils of nazism
the holocaust might have been halted
just as the mental defective
elimination program was disbanded after
catholic leaders in the thirties
had done it it's said that pope pius
feared that the
if he condemned them the nazis might
bomb the vatican
take him prisoner well that would be an
admission of cowardice
or at least a concern to save the wealth
and splendor of the church
by doing the wrong thing the document
shows there was never any danger
that the nazis would attack all they
asked of the pope was his silence
and they received it not all
popes of course are bad or incapable of
moral understanding
pope pius xi achillerati who'd allowed
fascist flags to fly in his cathedral in
the early days after kristallnacht
and the italian race laws commissioned
three leading jesuits to draft an
encyclical
yes it remained on his desk
when he died his successor his successor
never
issued it uh the unity of the human race
uh the encyclical against nazism
racism spread its poison unchecked and
undiluted
by a man who claimed to be the world
moral leader
mr pacelli the bad samaritan
jeffrey thank you very much and thank
you for wrapping that up rather rapidly
um i'd like to i'd like to a
very very warm welcome to ron richlack a
professor of law at the university of
mississippi
and the author of hitler the war and the
pope
ron is our final speaker against the
motion pope
pius xii did too little to save the jews
from the holocaust
thank you very much it is
it's very nice to be back in england
i've
twice of taught summers at downing
college in cambridge
the last time i taught there uh my wife
and our five daughters were there
in a small row house with one bathroom
it was the most productive summer of my
life because i got out of the house very
quickly over the office
before that all started i did just come
from a conference at the sorbonne
uh in paris uh where they brought
together scholars on pius xii
from uh they're from france from germany
from israel from
the uk from the united states um some
other
nations i'm sure i'm forgetting at the
very end the convener
the provost from the sorbonne said
no one in this room would use the term
hitler's pope it's ridiculous
because the arguments that we're hearing
from our worthy opponents tonight
are arguments that were valid perhaps
five or ten years ago before serious
research
was done on many of these things however
as we say in the united states you're
entitled to your own opinion but not
your own facts
and i think the facts are very distorted
what we've heard tonight
uh i want to go directly to the
vizzacker statements
and going to his communications to
germany what about what he was saying to
the vatican
at the same time he was saying to the
vatican to please don't make a statement
if you do we will immediately come in
and round up all the jews
about 2 000 were rounded up originally
about a thousand were released
the 1000 did get shipped off and were
killed
but the vast majority of jews in rome
were saved and were saved directly by
intervention
by rescue by opening up every seminary
every convent in fact there are pictures
of the papal summer home where
not only in every room but up and down
the hallways up and down the staircases
people were sleeping because the the
rooms the buildings were made available
to refugees
not only to jews there were there were
others there were down british airmen
who were being sheltered there were
gypsies that you know
there were there were there were uh awol
german soldiers
who were given uh protection by the
church at the time
uh but but to think that that it was an
uncaring pope that was doing these
things
is simply ridiculous and and not
feasible today
in fact at the end of the occupation in
rome
the chief rabbi of rome who had been
protected by the church converted to
catholicism
now he said this he said i did this
because it was a true conversion a
vision of jesus it was not
and thanks and tribute to the pope
however he
did take as his christian name eugenio
in tribute to the pope
and he did have the pope serve as his
godfather or sponsor into the church
he rec and he spoke profoundly about all
the church had done
to protect jews during this time in fact
there was a a
statement of tribute put up at the
synagogue in rome thanking the church
and the pope
for all that has done the pope a
reference made earlier about the pope
and his delicate stomach the pope went
on wartime rations
during the war the people out in rome
could not have
hot coffee so he could not have hot
coffee although he was over six feet
tall he weighed 118 pounds
by the end of the war he saw his parents
bodies blown
out of their their crips when bombs fell
upon rome
in terms of what he did early in the war
one perhaps one of the most amazing
things
uh he actually forwarded information
about german troop movements 10 days
before the
the german troops went into the lowlands
afterwards he sent telegrams
to the leaders of those nations
expressing his
deep regret what had happened promising
better days would come in the future
telling them not to give up hope he
outraged mussolini
because he'd clearly sided against
mussolini's ally
adolf hitler pius on the other hand had
very close relations
with franklin delano roosevelt it
established the beginning of
what eventually would become formal
recognition formal relationship
with the united states there's an
amazing book about the letters back and
forth at the very end of the war
fdr wrote pius thanking him for his
collaboration
against religious and racial persecution
and in context that could be nothing but
uh what he did
in terms of helping with the jews
why not a more exacting
bully pulpit kind of statement from the
pope well there were
several pieces of information that he
had going that he had to rely upon
one of them was he wrote an important
statement
about the nazi occupation in poland
and he had it smuggled into the
archbishop who was in charge of the
church in poland
and the archbishop looked at it burned
the letter
sent a note back in vatican archives now
saying holy father thank you so much for
the statement
it's so important the people are pulling
you know to know that you feel this way
but i can't do this because this will
get people killed
a similar thing happened in holland
where the bishops made a statement
and it got people killed this is the
information coming back to the vatican
the vatican the pope had to decide where
can i make an effective intervention
the bishops in the united states were
very outspoken
expressly talking about jews and the
nazis and hitler
how come a free press that was not
suppressed
that would actually get around to people
at least in that nation
and no risk of retaliation that you
faced
every place else that the pope might
have made
a statement the pope relied upon his
bishops what did they say if a bishop
could be more forceful
they would bishop would be more forceful
less forceful
that's what you had to do the pope
didn't come down
and and enforce a uniform approach in
every location
he relied upon the catholic doctrine of
subsidiarity which says you know let's
look locally
and deal the best we can that way
uh by the way some pontifications the
first encyclical issue by the pope
six weeks after the outbreak of war did
in fact uh
refer to jews and quote a scripture
saying there is no
gentile or jew uh in the church
during that time the pope was also very
active with vatican radio and vatican
the vatican newspaper
prompting many protests in fact
the the nazis called the vatican radio
the
mouthpiece of the jewish war criminal
um in terms of actual threats to the
pope
there was an order and i have the
transcript of my book from the german
general who got the order
from hitler to draw plans to invad to
invade the vatican
and capture the pope the pope held a
meeting with a curia discussing what was
going to happen
when the nazis came in because everyone
thought it was going to come
the nazis were just across there was a
white line rome was occupied
there's a white line on the ground on
one side you've got nazis with
submachine guns
on the other side you've got the swiss
soldiers with their their pikes
so it's not going to put up much of a
defense for very long when the nazis
decide
the nazis on the ground convinced hitler
not to do this because they said if you
invade the vatican
the italians will will not tolerate this
it will be impossible for us to maintain
the occupation
so you have to back off on this and
that's how eventually the
the invasion the kidnapping did not take
place
however that was a very serious threat
upon the liberation of rome mussolini is
out of office the king has fled
everyone comes out of hiding in fleets
of the vatican cheering the pope the
defender of the city
pius xii said jews for too late for you
know have
long been tolerated but we have to move
past that now it's time to welcome
them as our friends the israeli
philharmonic
uh in nineteen 1955 i think was later on
came and played a concert of tribute of
thanks for all the vatican had done
for saving jews during the war while
there they offered the future pope paul
vi
a medal for all he had done he said i
only did what the pope told me
don't don't give me a medal for that
john the 23rd when offered thanks for
all he did essentially said the same
thing i only carried out
the pope's orders first and foremost to
save human lives
these types of statements this kind
of information refutes the accusation
that the pope did little or did nothing
um
the uh the state of israel i'm touching
that because that by the way was an
important point
at the at the conference in paris in
paris no one argues about whether the
pope should have
we didn't talk about the pope so much it
was really ancillary things but there
was debate about
how the pope felt about the state of
israel the pope agreed with the
establishment of
a an israeli state somewhere he wasn't
certain about whether it should be
located
where it is located today however when
the vote came up in the united nations a
coalition of about 30
catholic nations came to the pope and
said is it okay
for us to vote in favor of locating the
israeli state
in this location and he said that would
be acceptable 17 of them did 11 did not
but he was in a situation where he could
have said no vote against it
he did not say that so with respect to
the rules i will wrap it up at this
point thank you
thank you very much uh ron richlack and
thank you for
uh sticking very uh precisely to your
time
um now thank you to all our
distinguished speakers
and now is the time for uh you the
audience to ask some questions but
before you do let me tell you
how the voting has gone so um
before the debate for the motion so
against pope pius xii 146 of you
against the motion so supporters of pope
pius coming in
41 of you however there were 170 of you
who didn't know
so this is all to play for the floor is
now
yours i'll take questions in bunches the
lights are quite
uh bright so so so if i haven't seen you
do wave your arms about so there's
someone there in the front row
and then i'll take the person up there
in the top left
and then after that the person right up
in the back so
the person in the middle in the front
row go go ahead yes
um so thanks very much gentlemen for
your comments and your contributions um
i was there when jeffrey robertson spoke
against the current pope
at the time of the papal visit and his
gift of fiction has not decreased
uh one of the heinrich himmler a devout
catholic never heard that before
but you're introducing yourself sorry
make sure to ask a question
i'm just about to my name's peter
williams and my question would be given
that uh jeffrey robinson brought up that
piece of fiction the stelvio the deputy
um the play by ralph hochov what does he
and indeed the rest of the panel think
of the comments by john michael pachaypa
who was the head of
one of the romanian spy masters who
defected to the west and has spoken
recently about how he knew the kgb fed
documents
doctored documents to roth occur
deliberately
to slander the pope and to discredit the
vatican
very good um this gentleman up here
uh bernard hermann two short questions
for the opposition very shortly and yes
in 1917
in munich which has been referred to the
purple
nancy pachelli refused to assist the
jewish community unlike his predecessor
in allowing the importation of a
tabernacle with the jewish festival of
sukhos
through the mutual offices of the
vatican which was completely surprising
to the jewish community at the time
my second question is rome was liberated
upon june
4th 1944 the deportations of the
hungarian jewish community
did not conclude until july the 27th
1944
in intervening six weeks about 200 000
jews were deported
now the pope would have had no problems
with no threat from the german occupying
forces during those six weeks
as far as i'm aware he said nothing or
did nothing
thank you then we had someone right up
at the back there
no i think who's uh whose question's
obviously
already been asked so is there one more
question i have someone in the middle
there yes
uh i like your reaction the last uh
could you introduce yourself sorry my
name's david franklin um
the last speaker um
surely your last comment nullified the
entire
direction of your argument in that
if the pope wasn't certain where the
jewish state
should be where jesus christ
lived in lived in jerusalem
where the jewish state was originally
formed a thousand years before
the whole history of the jews was being
was in
jerusalem and in the area known as
israel
how in this in any way could indicate
that
the pope had warm feelings towards the
jews
whereas there is only one place in the
world that is
undoubtedly connected to judaism thank
you
good three excellent questions jeffrey
on the kgb
slander well
so be it uh the
communists don't need to invent
the pope's silence the pope silence
speaks for itself so to speak uh
it was it's there as a matter of history
he never mentioned the jews he never
mentioned the
concentration camps he never condemned
the final solution
he didn't need the communists so quite
frankly
whether i think it's a romanian journal
isn't it who's
sorry spymaster spymaster yes
it happens i'm uh i have a university
degree from
bucharest and i know a number of uh
romanian generals who
have a very low opinion of this
particular spy master
but i won't play that card i will simply
say
i will sit i will simply say that
john julius here is not renowned for
taking moscow gold
and the cases i'm doing at the moment
happen to be against russia the ukraine
and georgia
uh for the stalinist uh perceptions that
still
cover their court so we're not communist
dukes
uh it didn't i i'm sure that the
communists were very
happy to see this issue raised by the
hook of play
in 1963 but uh
you know it it it was a play and does
anyone on this side want to comment on
the kgb
conspiracy theory yeah i would be happy
to i have uh
been working with ian maher pachapa who
uh
i the thing that that uh just to give an
example
of how communist uh infiltration or
disinformation affected the the approach
to pope pius xii
after world war ii former catholic
croatia is now under soviet domination
cardinals in the united states we say
steppen act
in croatia they say the peanuts was was
given a show trial
false information was manufactured to
indicate
that he was complicit with with the
natasha regime uh
in the 1960s when the issue breaks about
pope pius xii
uh falcone carl falcone
decides to write a book and in trying to
find evidence he goes to the prosecution
from croatia and he writes an entire
book about pope pius xii
based upon this croatian information
which we now know is doctored and yet
that book has influenced uh the study of
pius xii throughout
john cornwall uh accredited falcone for
his magnificent work he did
cited it frequently but after
uh yugoslavia came out after uh from the
thumb of communism
the first thing they did was apologize
for this show trial the records show
that the evidence was manufactured
but it's tainted the entire perception
and the viewpoint and
the the vision from which we look at
pius xii
so so william do we know what's coming
in this question yeah i just want to add
one thing it's not difficult to
understand
why the soviets began their campaign at
the end of the second world war
nazism having been defeated the great
struggle was then between
christianity and the churches more or
less and western civilization that
that were sympathetic to them and the
communist world now today because
communism has become so disgraceful
we tend to think it's incredible that
anyone and so many people
would have been in trance with comets
but at the time it was very real
and i have two articles right in front
of me from 1946
and from 1947 where the communist
campaign is already underway
proved that the soviet newspaper alleges
pius hitler
hitler pact and again in 1947 russian
says pope shields fascists so the the
campaign
against pius 12th as hitler's pope as
shielding nazi warfares which by the way
is not true he supported the nazis
so this side believes that there is
motivation oh there's no question
for the for the doctrine of the evidence
now john julius would you like to
comment on the kgb
well i mean i think again this is the
same old thing that
uh if you forgive my saying so
uh that uh america is always worried
about i mean there's
there's always the tendency to see
comedy under the reds under the bed
uh i don't think excuse me sir 20
million people
have died and they're not under the bed
they're in the brain they're in graves
sir so don't make
light of that fact i'm not latin yes you
are no no i'm not on the country
but i see i remember which i don't think
perhaps
i don't have to but i remember i
remember the whole of
the years of the of eugene mccarthy
i remember all that going on and
everybody was being accused of being a
communist
and i think that there is only one thing
we need to remember which i'm
absolutely accept which is that for
evgenia parcelli
communism was worse than nazis
absolutely obviously now this is
absolutely
nobody nobody argues that nobody's ever
wronged
absolutely of course we do i don't think
i've certainly not argued
myself and i can't see anybody else he's
told numerous ministers
that the first thing that we have to do
is defeat adolf hitler and as a matter
of fact
because he was the greater danger and as
a matter of fact they wanted him to
condemn the communists during the war
and he
intervened and he said because they
because america wanted to give
aid to russia and a lot of people
thought that the pope would condemn them
in fact
he intervened in defense of american
lend lease precisely to help stan
defeat hitler he wanted us to
the pope's attitude towards communism
let's go to the so there are
there are some more uh rather detailed
historical questions
does anyone on this side like to take uh
the 1917
refusal to assist the jewish community
for
the festival and uh 1944
this time between the hungarian between
the liberation of rome and the hungarian
deportation well i just
mentioned one thing on the hungering
question one of the greatest jewish
historians
ever general levi he is among the first
and greatest historians he has written
an entire book called
pope pius 12th was not silent hungarian
jewry and the papacy
and he shows contrary to what was
implied that in fact at the very
earliest stages
pope pius felt was any instructions and
on his behalf
there were statements and vigorous
protests against the deportations now of
course he couldn't control the many of
hitler and his forces
but he took a very strong stand and i
would suggest that anyone who wants to
read about this
should read the book pius 12th was not
silent hungarian jewelry in the papacy
by general levi
because he details the fact that pius
12th was not silent
and he did speak out okay so on that
point simply untrue anyone wants to pick
up 1977
munich the the 1917 letter uh
is the one where uh a jewish uh leader
came to
the future pope is the 12th and asked
for assistance in obtaining palm fronds
to carry out uh a jewish ceremony and uh
and and and pius who essentially was a
low-level administrator at this time
said i can't help you uh and and he
wrote to rome the letter the letter
where he said uh this is not a matter of
life and death this is not a matter of
of helping someone who's isn't suffering
this is a matter of a religious thing
the import
the this would have required violating
italian
export import rules at that time he said
we simply can't do this
for this situation that's what it was
then the the letter came back
from rome saying congratulations on
handle this handling this
appropriately john cornwell
mistranslated that and said
for your shrewdness in handling this
implying some underhandedness but that
was not
the proper translation of that letter
any i think i'm
right in saying that actually when paz
had uh he's he or he he he gave a
perfectly nice
correct answer uh to the head of the
jewish community
and said i will forward you but i don't
think there's very much chance of it
happening and
it's all very difficult now in the
problems i can really offer you very
little hope then he reports back
to rome and says i didn't see why i
should help them
uh in the in the uh uh
practice of their jewish cult
but i think that was the actual phrase
now you might say
cult is is perhaps another unfortunate
word because it in english it's loaded
yeah it may not have been so it may not
have been so loaded in italian
is a perfectly okay uh italian i think
that
that is a little unfair and i'd like to
make that point well i'm great
nonetheless i think
the reason he didn't want to do it was
because he didn't want to he
he didn't really want to help the
children well it was because he said it
was not a matter of
life saving or or something like that he
said it was for a religious cult
he really did believe that they were the
sinners who had responsible for their
killing
that's absolutely incorrect and that
is why you talk about the israeli
philharmonic and so on
the reasons why the pope was
congratulated by some
jewish leaders who wrote about the
reasons later was firstly because they
were thanking
a number of catholics who had helped
towards the end of the war to save them
secondly because they wanted they
asked the pope to issue a refutation
of this blood libel that they were
responsible for because they saw it as
encouraging the holocaust and he didn't
and then of course thirdly they wanted
him to recognize
the state of israel which he said i
think it's important
i think it's very offensive to to
question
the genuine appreciation
of the jewish community for pope pius
xii he is subtly implying that their
motives were something other than that
and i think that's wrong
can we move on to the another important
question which is
uh which is the jewish state and not
wanting to recognize this in
historic uh uh historic
well yeah i i don't think it nullifies
everything uh
uh the pope was concerned that if we we
established
number one i don't think you should say
jewish people have one place where
where they should be allowed to be or
can you know or
tied because that was the suggestion in
the question the pope said
they haven't i see the need for a
homeland i recognize establishing a
homeland
he said if you put it here i'm worried
about what's going to happen
is you know there might be some violence
in the long run if you put him there
you know but but when the point came
when push came to shove
and the catholic nations that were
members of the united nations
came to him and said should we vote
against this he said no you don't have
to vote against it
do what you think is right the majority
voted for it he could have said
you know vote against it and they would
have let me just see if there's any
do would you like to uh anyone on this
side like to
comment on his attitude towards israel
he was doing what he always did he was
avoiding the issue
he he wouldn't take a stand even on that
he said you do what you like
he wouldn't even say yes do it or don't
i would refer my distinguished
colleagues to
an obituary in the jewish chronicle uh
in october
when did the battery come in excuse me
1994.
excuse me october the 10th 1958 the day
after
pius 12 died and the jewish chronicle
points out that as early as 1917 this is
the year he was supposedly indifferent
to the jewish community according to our
colleagues
1917 he he helped nahom sokolop who was
an early zionist leader
who wanted an established homeland for
the jews he he
created an opportunity for him to meet
with the pope and
during the after 1917 he kept in good
close contact with nehemiah
right up until zakalov's death i should
also point out that in 1944
when pope pius 12 was pope uh according
to the jewish chronicle he told lord
gort the newly appointed
high commissioner for palestine that he
would have no problem and he would not
want to interfere
with uh the establishment of a jewish
homeland
in the state of palestine and that he
was filled with profound sympathy for
the jews
so the reality that he was the the
supposition that he was hostile
to a jewish homeland is completely false
now he was concerned
about how to work out the arrangement of
diplomatic relations regarding
what would be done how the christian
community would relate to the new jewish
state
and how they would relate to the arab
community and so on those are
concerns that are still with us but on
the fundamental issue was he sympathetic
to a jewish state he was
he was and this is confirmed and by the
way jeffrey's question of when did uh
when did the vatican recognize not until
1993 but that doesn't mean
and if let me yeah can i can i reply to
that
that's a that's a fair point i myself
supported this uh
establishment in the state of israel but
the israeli foreign ministry themselves
in
1948 and i have it right here they said
we understand why the pope is hesitating
to establish formal death regulations
because there was a lot of
hostility to put it mildly among the
arab communities against
jews and against any christians who
supported them and if he had done it at
that time
it would have been it would have been
created a ferocious attack against
everyone and would have created
a terrible situation but one last thing
no no let's
move to take another round of questions
this is um
the the lady uh in in the black and
white shirt
uh up here just uh yes
two two in black and white shirts well
they must yes so and then and then
behind exactly
um and then
and then ah sorry up yes um i can hardly
see but i can
i can i can see some waving so we'll go
upstairs after
after you hi so um my name is anne
throwdall
um a very simple question after the very
erudite previous questions
um what i thought was sort of the most
interesting that the con
the speakers didn't address was that
there were no
requiem masses recognizing the
loss of jewish lives during the
holocaust
and is that the case are we just jaded
because there have been so many
remembrance services in modern times
very very good question um then
that there were two hands up in the in
the balcony
um and then hold your question for the
next round
so you've got a microphone coming so two
seconds
uh my question i'm sorry robert
carnathan um
my my question was do might
your present eyes sort of um
color how you see the situation when we
look back now
we know that hitler was a madman hitler
was evil
but at the time um fdr who i think was
mentioned
positively was saying to his ambassador
to the nazi
court take it easy don't push back just
go along and don't make waves and i
wonder if the pope
at that time if he's
in it instead of looking back with the
benefit of of
what we now know does that maybe color
how you
view him because you think he should
have been harder at the time
maybe you should have known he should
have known more okay i think we've got
that and then there's someone just in
front of you yes
well i've got something my name's
nicholas johnson
um there are two related questions the
first is really rather
more of a point than a question but
isn't it correct to say that the british
government itself had considerable
misgivings
about the creation of the state of
israel in 1947 and 1948
firstly and
secondly perhaps the um critics of the
pope and i suppose by extension the
institution of the catholic church
might like to explain why the nazis
um had such a bitter hatred of the
catholic church if it was such a
an emollient fellow traveller
why is it clear from their statements
that if they had won the war that they
would have taken
action to exterminate and eradicate um
roman catholicism in germany and and i
would add not lutheranism
since the lutheran church had largely
gone over to the nazis
thank you okay so the first question
would you like who would like to take
the question on requiem masses no
requiem
yes i will take that question this is a
completely mis uninformed
uh assumption if there's one thing we
have to understand about popeye's truth
is that he truly understood what the
word catholic means
catholic means all embracing it means
universal every time he said a mass
every time he issued praise it was for
everyone and he constantly spoke about
the suffering of the jews it is
absolutely false to say that he was
indifferent or silent
uh our our colleague mr robertson
said that at no time did he ever speak
out i have and he mentioned
in particular the german foreign
minister riben trump i have an article
here
in 1940 very early on the word which
states
pope is emphatic about just peace jews
rights defend
and in the body of the article it says
it was also learned today that in the
confrontational
meeting that pius 12th had with ribbon
top it was learned
that uh pius xii also came to the
defense of the jews
in germany and poland so he did speak
out and he did so in a very personal way
okay
that wasn't about masses
it is common ground or it should be it's
historical fact you can read it
in john julius's book about the popes uh
which isn't anti-catholic
you can read it in under his very
windows a very good book by susan
zaccotti although she'll probably be
condemned as a communist dupe
that he didn't ever publicly
mentioned the jews the guest chambers of
the final
solution uh there were jeffrey is this
is this is
okay this is uh an answer to that
question is it
because we do have a lot of questions to
get through okay
the simple fact is there were no messes
i hope you frame that and that you're
uh um who would like to make a comment
who would like to make a comment on the
difficulty the historian's difficulty
of looking back how do you judge what
it would have been like to have been in
that situation at the time
are we using too much hindsight in
condemning is this side using too much
hindsight in condemning the pope
wasn't there quite a lot quite
condensing it wasn't there quite a lot
of ambivalence towards
the nazi regime there was ambivalence
towards the nazi regime i think in the
1930s
uh certainly by uh by
1939 there was virtually no
ambivalence i know of in in this country
at all there was considerable
ambitions of course in america there
were
there was lindbergh and father cochran
all
that uh strong isolationism
but in this particular country i think
we had absolutely
or with very very few exceptions uh
in the 1930s perhaps yes but by
1940 uh i mean good heavens we've seen
hitler breaking every promise uh we'd
seen we we'd let down czechoslovakia
ourselves
we weren't going to do it with poland he
was perfectly obvious he was going to
go on he didn't do with jews he was god
and god knows he was doing
bad enough things with them but this was
also the
general expansion the aggrandizement of
nazi germany
and nobody could watch that and and not
feel petrified you can't be neutral in
the face
of the gas chambers in the face of the
final solution to exterminate
a human race uh what do you need to know
about the gastro
well towards the end they do at the end
of this yeah
and then neutrality becomes
a morality and at the nuremberg trials
it was fascinating
when they showed to the nuremberg
defendants and the whole court
pictures of belson and auschwitz
that afternoon at nuremberg goring and
all the nazi defendants hid their eyes
they couldn't face it
nice william william i just want to say
one thing very clearly the fact of the
matter is that pope pius 12 did condemn
the holocaust in his 1942 christmas
dress as well as in the june 2nd
1943 allocation to the college of carlen
in which he explicitly used the term
extermination of people based upon the
race now that was crystal clear language
everybody at the time understood and so
the claim is that once he knew
he did condem but he didn't he did
condemn it and he was condemned by the
nazis as a mouthpiece of the jewish war
criminals for doing that
mr robertson has things completely
reversed where did he mention the jews
he he mentioned the jews in the
confrontational meeting with
yes
when did he know that the final solution
was underway
well he he could not confirm it
independently but he knew that it was
going on as early as late
1941 early 1942 and when as the
information came in
he had vatican excuse me i've got the
actual words that he said to the college
of cardinals on the 2nd of june 1943 on
which you rely
he said and i quote those who have
turned an
anxiously imploring eye to us tormented
as they are
for reasons of their nationality or
dissent by major misfortunes
and by more acute and grave suffering
and destined sometimes
even without guilt on their part to
exterminatory measures
no mention of jews nazis racism
excuse me gas chambers that's your
evidence excuse me that's not my
evidence
we have we have a whole book an 80 000
word annotated bibliography of evidence
which you obviously have not read
and i would like to say one thing i've
got it yeah no
that that's not that's not the book i
was referring to
yes that's that's wrong book you have to
i will be glad
i i will be happy to send you an
autographed copy of the pious work
now um can we okay thank you
there was there was another very good
question which was
why uh if your side is right
did the nazis hate the catholic church
so
and the catholic more than the lutheran
church
well because the catholics had stopped
their extermination of the mentally
disordered in the 30s and i have i think
it's very interesting that hitler
is supposed to have said to general wolf
at one point
that we might have to attack the vatican
and you would be in charge
of securing protecting the pope uh
and perhaps moving him to liechtenstein
under
our protection and ribentrop went mad
and he said this let me quote ribbon
trop
if you send an aircraft over to bomb the
vatican
it will be the last move we the nazis
will make our own people the germans can
overlook much
even our attacks on priests in other
countries
but if we attack the vatican we will
most assuredly
have a civil war in germany within the
hour the first bomb falls
so they're not and that ended any
question of
attacking the vatican so the nazis
themselves were aware
that if they bombed the vatican they'd
have civil war
in germany uh so i think that's
yet more uh evidence to show
that the nazis really all they asked of
the pope
was to stay silent so so and they would
never have that
the hatred of the church is evidence of
the power of the church and the power
which was not used i think is the
argument
on that side which is absurd uh the uh
it was the church's uh continual
intervention
not see the point is it's not the pope
it's the bishops
it's it's at the local level because if
the pope responds in a given way
that's applied across the universe
across the
occupied area a statement from the pope
isn't going to get
into occupied areas where the everything
is controlled
uh it's not going to have any in fact
that way
if it does it's going to lead to
retaliation and bad stuff so the pope
said
let my bishops where they can press for
more do more
let my bishops where they know it's
going to cause bad stuff
uh you know do what they can if the best
we can do
is hide and shelter let's hide in
shelter if we can give false baptismal
certificates
so that jews can show that they in fact
have been baptized and therefore not
subject to deportation
let's do that if we can provide food and
clothing let's do that
you know whatever we can do let's do as
much as we can do but let's do it by
focusing on the ground level
okay now we're running short on time
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take as many questions as i can take
and if you could uh listen to those
questions and maybe integrate
any points that you want to pick up in
your summing up speeches
so the lady right in the front row and
then
in the blue shirt the front
carol conrad in amongst this very heated
exchange it seems to me we've lost sight
of the
motion which said pope pius did too
little
to save the jews from the holocaust many
of mr donah's statements
show that he tried to do something but
that doesn't mean that he did
enough and i think we should as we are
about to vote focus
on what the motion is actually about
very good can i uh can i ask jeffrey
robertson
my old friend can you introduce me sorry
daniel johnson
editor of standpoint uh jeffrey's one of
my contributors
um can i ask him is it or is it not the
case that when the dutch bishops
did condemn the deportation of the jews
there was a massive roundup
specifically actually of jews who
converted to catholicism one of the
victims who was taken to auschwitz was
of course edith stein
later canonized great philosopher yeah
so in other words there was a genuine
fear
in the vatican that being too
explicit might lead to that kind of
retaliation and this wasn't a fantasy
okay understood we uh we have someone up
in the gallery
and while the microphone gets to you um
the
lady right in the middle in the in the
uh
stripe or tartan i can't quite see
and and then we'll go to the bottom here
and then to the gallery
no no sorry wait a second this one first
hello um
helena scott those who um remember the
storm of protest from jewish people
around the world
i think as late as the 1990s when
there was an attempt to establish a
carmelite convent
at auschwitz um there was such a protest
from jewish people
that uh the convent in fact had to be
moved
um can those who remember this really
condemn
pope pius xii um as
anti-jewish for not saying requiem
masses for jewish people which might
have provoked for a provoked
unequal protest for all we know
um secondly um those uh
coming back to this very thorny issue of
the state of israel
who look at the state of israel now and
the question of the palestinian people
and what is happening to them
can they really condemn pope pius xii as
anti-jewish
for being reluctant to say firmly that
the jewish
state should be in that particular piece
of land
thank you down here and then we'll go up
to the top yes
um my name is selena o'grady and my
question is a very simple one
why after the war did the pope not
excommunicate
any answers very good
in the gallery yeah i'm andrew benson
um in those in those difficult times
and um jeffrey robertson
um noted that it was uh incredibly
difficult times
and he also noted that the pope at that
point in time was aware that
the the nazi germany was killing priests
i mean he had to make difficult uh
decisions and mighty possibly have made
the decision to try and
protect his own flock as a priority over
protecting
a different flock and that no matter how
bad that was
and and that wish to protect his
flock was perceived or can be conveyed
as anti-semitism
when it was simply a decision of
priority to protect his his catholic
church okay um we probably have time for
just one or two very short questions
um uh okay this one yes gentleman with
the glasses
halfway up and then the young man right
at the back
uh my name's simon levine i'm no
relation to the bolshevik max
question for ronald richard do you think
when the pope died and he went to heaven
and met
and peter at the gates some peter said
you did a great job and you were
effective
in you know at the edges trying to
uh do the right thing down there on
earth do you think that you'd have got a
pat on the back or do you think that uh
i i think we've got by the greatest
judge that there is uh
he might have been marked down a little
bit thank you
um and then final question uh young man
at the back
um before our summing up speeches
uh i'm thomas burick and um
my question is uh what if the pope
really wanted to save
jewish lives then why didn't he speak
out
against hitler excommunicate him and
say about how bad well how
horrible the things he had done thank
you
for that question um right we're now
going to go to the vote
remember that if you have been convinced
by
this side of the argument then you want
to put your agree slip in
if you've been convinced by this side of
the argument disagree if you still don't
know please put both of them in
while the voting is going to be uh uh is
proceeding we will
ask our speakers to sum up and to take
into account the questions that they
have just heard so going in reverse
order
ronald no do stay at stay at your
uh stay at the same table
voting is important but please let the
speakers uh
please be quiet while the speakers sum
up i suppose suppose two of the
questions one directed
to me uh but we're fairly similar about
how in the end we assess pope pius xii
for how he is assessed
uh and i believe that
in a very difficult situation
he did what the best i think he did the
best thing that he could do
if we take the literal uh uh thing po
did pope pius did do too little to save
the jews from the holocaust
he didn't stop the holocaust he tried to
stop the holocaust
he wanted to stop the holocaust he asked
for prayers
he he tried to stop the war i think no
one doubts that he wanted to end the war
he tried to end the war tried very hard
to end the war the holocaust could not
go on
but for the war if he'd been successful
in avoiding the war or stopping the war
he would have prevented the holocaust he
did what one man could do
i think he did more than any other
individual did i put the allied armies
ahead of him but i think uh there's a
headline from the new york times
that says uh the pope is speaking out of
the silence of a continent
uh he was the only one pointing his
finger at hitler that was the 1942
new york times uh editorial lead
editorial the
pious 12 more than ever was was
identifying hitler
in in a very confined context there's a
matter of what can you do
the truth of the matter is at the end of
the day the nazis despised the pope
the rescuers cited him as their
inspiration
and there were lesion a legion of
victims who thanked him and offered him
the the greatest praise you could get
from gold to my ear to virtually every
major jewish group
both at the end of the war again at his
death
wrote to the vatican offering their
thanks to him those are the real
witnesses
those are the people we need to listen
to and i appreciate you listening to me
tonight
thank you
jeffrey you have two to three minutes
well i'll only say this that edith stein
who we
share admiration for wrote as early as
1933 a wonderful letter
uh saying that he should the former pope
should
ershesh issue an encyclical condemning
both the nazi attacks on the jews and
the
attacks on catholics and i agree
that there was a genuine argument in the
vatican
over whether speaking out would
uh cause more trouble than uh
it was worth and the pros and cons were
discussed
but over five years from uh
the beginning of the war in 39 right to
the end
it said every day it was discussed every
day the wrong decision
as the evidence comes out as auschwitz
in 1944 becomes clear
what is being done is of such monstrous
and unprecedented evil that any man of
god
in our submission must have done more
than he did
obviously the pope didn't was not
a nazi he was not in hitler's pocket
but he did what the nazi wanted the
nazis wanted
all they wanted was that he should
remain silent
and he did when the germans
entered rome there was one thing von
weisicker did
want he wanted a document to satisfy
to to satisfy the world
that they treated the vatican well and
the pope
signed that document he went on as
you've heard from those telegrams which
i think are devastating evidence
that the pope did not do as much as he
could
and uh for the leader of the great
religion
as much as he should he should have
spoken out
uh there was certainly concerns that
speaking out
would lead to more danger uh as i've
read you from von ribentrop's
memorandum to hitler there was never any
doubt
that the germans would the nazis would
not have
bombed or attacked the pope by or
or they would have had civil war but uh
to make to wake up every morning in
between 1939 or like in fact it was
first known with slovakia in 1941 and
croatia
uh until the very end of the war until
in our view until 1958 when he died
he never spoke out to denounce this
horror
he could have done more
thank you very much i think we've
already replied to the statements that
our opponents have made
the pope did speak out he did intervene
quite forcefully during the german
occupation of rome and the nazis hated
them because of it
i just like to bring the subject back to
uh
what the lady said very generously she
said i have shown
that the pope of course did something
but did he do enough
ladies and gentlemen could any of us say
that anyone did enough
when six million people died no one
quote did enough not even the most
righteous gentiles
that's not the question whether one
person had the power to do enough you
could always say that
even the most righteous gentile the
question was given the extreme
situation the life and death daily
situation that pope pius
12 faced did he do what was reasonably
expected of the vicar of christ
and we know from the catholic rescuers
themselves the answer is an overwhelming
yes
let me just cite you one priest who was
in turn in the concentration camp what
he had to say about this matter he said
during pious quote this is father
mikhail michelle rickway who spent years
in a concentration camp because of
his stand against the nazis quote pius
xii has spoken
pius xii has condemned pius xii has
acted
throughout those years of horror when we
listened to radio vatican
and to the pope's messages we felt in
communion with the pope
in helping persecuted jews and fighting
against nazi violence
i pointed out in my opening statement
that as early as 1930
as the cardinal secretary of state adolf
hitler himself was condemned
the german bishops in fact did try
excommunication against hitler in the
nazis and it didn't work
people who are apostates who are mad men
they don't pay attention to things like
that
okay one last thing i want to say if
there's one
i want to say this from the bottom of my
heart okay i have spent years
involved in the jewish christian
dialogue and if i believe for one second
that pope pius xii was anti-semitic that
he did not do enough that he did too
little
that he turned his back on the jewish
community i would not defend him i would
not have come all the way to america to
defend
someone who i thought was a bad person
the reason but
the reason i am doing so ladies and
gentlemen is because every person i have
spoken to
who has worked with pope pius xii
during the rescue of so many jews
countless jews
told me that he was a good and honorable
and decent man and i'd just like to end
with one quotation
from one of the dearest priests that i
know monsignor john patrick carol abby
in his book but for the grace of god
he goes over all the questions that have
been raised tonight and he says
comparing what was actually being done
at the time by the pope
to what is now said today he said quote
never
in those tragic days could i foresee
even in my
wildest imaginings that the man who more
than any other
had tried to alleviate human suffering
had spent himself
day by day in the unceasing efforts
doing so
who would years later be made the
scapegoat for men trying to free
themselves from their own
responsibilities
and from the collective guilt that
obviously weighs so heavily upon them
this is a testimony of a man himself
monsignor carol abbing who fought the
nazis in conjunction with pope pius 12
to rescue so many jews and one last
question
i think it's very important for us not
to allow this situation
not to allow this controversy wherever
we stand to drive a wedge between the
jewish and christian community
it's we have come so far in so many ways
and it's too important
to allow the bonds of unity that we have
among christian jews
to allow good faith countries like this
but i do believe
the evidence is turning in favor of
pious 12th as indicated by yet hashem
and i'm very encouraged about the future
thank you all very much
you have three minutes well there is why
are we all here
we're here to debate we if
if pious the 12th had not left us
with some very very nasty questions uh
on our minds
uh we would not be here this evening
there's no smoke without a fire
we all have heard we've all known we
have all
sometimes some of us even remember right
some some of us even remember uh the
rage and frustration that people felt at
the time
i can remember my father in an absolute
fury um
about about about the silence of of paul
he uh he
uh he he made absolutely no secret of it
he
had a tremendous rouse with his catholic
friends
who tried to uh to defend to defend it
i think the problem was we all know that
he the the pious didn't speak out
whatever our
uh most eloquent um friends say
here about it the fact remains that even
they have not actually been able
to produce quotations where he spoke in
public mentioning the germans the nazis
and the jews
this there is there is no such quotation
because he'd be very careful
not to do it and all right perhaps he
felt that he was saving people's lives
and all that
but i think if you are the leader
of the greatest if you are a moral
leader of the st
of on the scale of the pope you
mustn't you you can't hide behind what
you think may be
better for people you've got to speak
out you've got to lead you can't lead
from behind and say oh well
it's so dangerous and a lot of people
might might get killed
you've got to stand up and say what you
believe and this is what pope pius xii
did not do i think that's
it seems to me to be as plain as that uh
here is a man who believed possibly that
he was doing right but in fact he was
doing desperately desperately wrong
and i think probably one of the reasons
i'm afraid
was covetous
thank you
ladies and gentlemen it's been a
fantastic debate and the vote is in
if you remember uh before the before the
debate
170 of you didn't know um
a lot of work convincing has been done
and it's now at 28.
now where did those votes go we had 146
before the debate for the motion and 41
against
coming out of the debate we have 227
for the motion and 103 against
so the fours carry the motion and they
also
carried the largest number of don't
knows
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
you